un funeral masivo en medio de un clima
de alta tensión miles de personas se
congregaron en la ciudad de nablús para
las compras fúnebres de dos palestinos
que perdieron la vida en una redada de
las fuerzas israelíes uno de ellos es
ibrahim alnabulsi alto comandante de la
brigada de los mártires de al-aqsa un
grupo armado vinculado con al fatá el
partido que controla cisjordania
pero ellos no ganaron hay cientos de
brahms y
hay millones de ibrahim millones no hay
solamente un ibrahim en el mundo
las tropas israelíes afirman que otro
militante cayó en la operación que fue
celebrada por el primer ministro ya ir
rápido la eliminación del terrorista
ibrahim al nabulsi es otro paso en
nuestra lucha intransigente contra el
terrorismo felicitó la acción combinada
de las organizaciones de seguridad que
llevó a cabo una acción selectiva con
gran éxito y sin víctimas el grupo de la
yihad islámica asegura que una
adolescente de 16 años también murió en
nablús por fuego israelí
en hebrón una multitud lamentó la muerte
de otro joven moment ya ver de 17 años
que murió a tiros por tropas israelíes
los informados reconocieron este deceso
y afirmaron que estaban respondiendo a
una protesta violenta
se trata de un martes de violencia que
llega dos días después de que entrara en
vigor una tregua entre israel y la yihad
islámica que puso fin a tres días de
intercambios de ataques que dejaron al
menos 46 palestinos muertos según las
autoridades sanitarias de este
territorio